DIRECTLY HIS THANKS FOR
EVERYTHING THAT EVERYONE ON
THE GROUND HERE HAS DONE,
SEAN.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, ED
HENRY, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
THAT REPORT.
WE APPRECIATE IT JOINING US
WITH MORE.
WE HAVE FORMER LAPD
DETECTIVE FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR MARK FUHRMAN
FORMER FBI AGENT.
LANNY I HAVE KNOWN YOU OVER
THE YEARS.
YOU HAVE SEEN A COUPLE OF
FLAWS IN WHAT I THINK -- YOU
ARE NEVER GOING TO CONVINCE
AN ANTIGUN PERSON TO BE
PRO-SECOND AMENDMENT AND
SIMILARLY I HAVE CARRIED A
WEAPON ALMOST ALL OF MY
ADULT LIFE.
I HAVE HAD CARRY PERMITS IN
NEW YORK, CALIFORNIA,
ALABAMA, GEORGIA AND RHODE
ISLAND.
I HAVE HAD CARRY PERMITS.
IT’S PART OF -- I WAS
TRAINED SINCE I’M 11 IN THE
USE OF A FIREARM.
SO, YOU ARE NOT GOING TO WIN
ON THAT DEBATE.
BUT SECURING THE SCHOOLS
WITH THE PROFESSIONALS TO ME
IS 1,000% DOABLE.
AND WE OWE IT TO THE KIDS TO
DO THIS.
>> WE DO.
WE DO.
AND THE ONLY THING THAT -- I
DON’T DISAGREE WITH YOU.
I JUST THINK THAT THERE IS A
BETTER APPROACH.
WHEN YOU HAVE RETIRED
PERSONNEL, THEY HAVE THE
BEST PART OF THEIR CAREER
BEHIND THEM, AND YOU NEED A
GENERATIONAL GAP THAT ISN’T
TWO OR THREE GENERATIONS
PERHAPS THE BETTER PART OF
ONE.
THESE OFFICERS ON THE SCHOOL
NEED TO BE ABLE TO INTERACT
WITH THESE STUDENTS AND GET
THAT INFORMATION THAT A GUY
LIKE CRUZ WOULD HAVE
SURFACED AND THEY WOULD HAVE
ACTUALLY CONFIDED IN THE
OFFICER.
YOU NEED TO GET SOME KIND OF
A SYSTEM WHERE HAVE YOU
PROTOCOLS FOR ALL THESE
SCHOOLS SO EVERYBODY IS
WORKING OFF THE SAME SHEET
OF MUSIC.
AND YOU NEED TO HARDEN THE
INSIDE TARGETS SO THE
SUSPECT CAN’T GET IN, AND
YOU CREATE THE TACTICAL
SITUATION FOR A SHOOTER ON
THE OUTSIDE, WHICH ALLOWS
RESPONDING OFFICERS AND THE
SECURITY OFFICERS TO TAKE
OUT THE SUSPECT WITH NO
DANGER TO THE STUDENTS.
I THINK THIS IS ALL POSSIBLE
WITHOUT GUN CONTROL.
>> Sean: ALL OF IT IS.
STRATEGICALLY AND
TACTICALLY.
LOOK, MY GUESS, MANNY, IS
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE
RETIRED MILITARY, RETIRED
POLICE OR MAYBE ACTIVE.
I THINK YOU CAN EVEN WORK IN
CONJUNCTION WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO GET THIS DONE
AND, AGAIN, IT WOULD BE
CONCEAL CARRY.
I THINK A LOT OF THE
STUDENTS WOULD BECOME
FRIENDS WITH THESE GUYS OVER
TIME AND MARK IS RIGHT.
WE CAN GET A LOT OF
INTELLIGENCE FROM THEM.
BUT STRATEGICALLY,
TACTICALLY, YOU SURROUND THE
PERIMETER.
YOU HAVE A FULL THREAT
ASSESSMENT, SECURITY
ASSESSMENT.
ALL -- WE KNOW THE ENTRY
POINT AT ANY POINT.
AND ALL OF THIS, EVERYBODY
GETS IN IS KNOWN.
NOBODY THAT IS UNKNOWN GETS
IN TO THAT SCHOOL, PERIOD,
END OF SENTENCE.
IT SEEMS DOABLE IF WE CHOOSE
TO DO IT.
>> I TOTALLY AGREE.
HAVING THE EXPERIENCE OF
FORMER MILITARY, FORMER LAW
ENFORCEMENT, WE JUST HAD A
WONDERFUL PIECE WHERE THE
COACH FROM THIS HIGH SCHOOL
SAVED LIVES.
THIS IS A COACH THAT KNEW
THESE STUDENTS.
HE WAS A FATHER-FIGURE
PERHAPS.
CERTAINLY AN ADULT FIGURE TO
THESE YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN.
THAT’S WHAT WE NEED.
WE NEED PEOPLE THAT THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE WILL RESPECT,
LOOK UP TO IF THEY HAVE
PROBLEMS.
WHETHER IT’S A ACTIVE
SHOOTER SITUATION OR ON A
MORE DAY-TO-DAY BASIS.
A DRUG CONDITION, A CRIMINAL
CONDITION, A BULLYING
CONDITION, THEY WILL GO UP
TO THESE FORMER LAW
ENFORCEMENT, FORMER MILITARY
ROLE MODELS AND BE ABLE TO
DISCUSS WITH THEM WHAT THEY
COULD DO TO HELP THE
SITUATION.
SO IT WILL BE A WIN-WIN-WIN
ON A DAILY BASIS.
>> Sean: FOR EVERYBODY.
>> ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
>> Sean: IF THEY ARE THERE
EVERY DAY.
LOOK, I WAS A KID SMOKING IN
THE BATHROOM.
I GOT TO KNOW THE JANITORS,
EVERYBODY BECAUSE THEY
WOULDN’T RAT ME OUT FOR WHEN
I WAS YOUNG AND STUPID.
BUT, IN ALL SERIOUSNESS,
THEY ARE GOING TO GET TO
KNOW THESE KIDS.
THOSE KIDS ARE GOING TO OPEN
UP TO THEM AND ALL THE
THINGS THAT THE KIDS ARE
SAYING POST THE SHOOTING.
THEY HAVE THE TRAINING AND
KNOWLEDGE AND HOW TO
INTERVENE IN A SITUATION
LIKE THAT.
>> AGREED.
>> I AGREE, SEAN.
WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEBODY
THAT’S INSIDE A SYSTEM LIKE
SCHOOL, YOU HAVE TO NOT ONLY
HAVE SECURITY, YOU HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE